news now all right if you lived in las
vegas for a long time you may remember
the popular nightclub near the strip
called drink and eat two which later
became known as ice now while it
shuddered back in 2006 turning into an
eyesore there are now some big plans for
it the site at koval and harman will be
part of the upcoming formula one race
that's right well construction is
underway there to become the start
finish line for the race and it's also
fueling a lot of excitement from those
in the area
[Music]
piece by piece the vacant ice nightclub
is becoming a thing of the past the
property on harmon and kovil will soon
have a major spotlight as formula one
speeds into las vegas at the end of next
year it is going to be a massive event
you're going to have a good time the
39-acre site was recently purchased by
formula one owner liberty media for an
estimated 240 million dollars angelo
defino with top golf las vegas says he's
excited about what the massive event
will bring to the city and his business
which is located across from this site
which is expected to become the starting
line all we know is we're going to have
a front row seat for it i mean it is
going to be right in front of us so
it is going to be an amazing thing to
watch the 50 lap las vegas grand prix is
expected to kick off from the pit area
north on koval around the msg sphere
west on sands to the las vegas strip
with speeds over 200 miles per hour you
can only imagine what that's going to
look like those cars driving down these
streets
it is going to be amazing for now this
property that was once a popular place
to go will become center stage for one
of the biggest events in las vegas
history it's all good for las vegas
that's for sure
exciting stuff there oh yes it is all
right come